my name is Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spider-Man and things are
going great
it's been five fun and speculative years
since the animated and very certified
fresh Spider-Man into the spider-verse
became somewhat of a surprise hit who
are you again this
this time has come the long-awaited
sequel is upon us so here is everything
you need to know about Spider-Man across
the spider-verse
here's what we're going to be slinging
into today
so let's swing on in and do this
[Music]
director of Miles Morales first appeared
in the comics in 2011. writer Brian
Michael Bendis was inspired to create a
new version of the character after a
failed attempt by fans to get Donald
Glover in as the next Spider-Man Miles
was originally made for Marvel's
Ultimate line of comics but his
popularity ultimately landed him
alongside Peter Parker in Marvel's
regular comics and then eventually onto
the big screen before finally nestling
comfortably in the annals of popular
culture not to mention in all of our
hearts yes I said annals look it up it
is a real word
in 2018's Spider-Man into the
spider-verse miles a biracial teenager
in Brooklyn is bitten by a radioactive
spider on the subway and suddenly
develops superpowers after he meets and
then Witnesses the death of the Peter
Parker of his world miles decides to try
and take over the mantle of Spider-Man
himself
hey he then takes on the bad guy Kingpin
who can open portals to other universes
is and brings other versions of
Spider-Man into this world thus miles
teams up with Gwen Stacy and an older
Peter named Peter B Parker not to
mention other awesome spider heroes from
around the Multiverse to knock Kingpin
down once and for all get it knock it
down like King Pin I'm an avid bowler
hey
talk about those universes bring us to
our next point if you thought the first
film had a lot of Multiverse action in
various Spidey iterations including
spider pig who has literally popped up
in my dreams you ain't seen nothing yet
my friends as we saw at the end of the
first movie Gwen Stacy had found a way
to reach miles in his bedroom from her
alternate Earth if only I can do that
with guys who don't text me back and it
turns out that she has joined a group of
spider heroes from across the Multiverse
who are calling themselves the spider
Society
looked at my uncle and ah let me guess
he died
anyways this time around instead of
welcoming more new friends to his
Universe miles is venturing out into the
universe as it says and we know that
this film will showcase at least six
universes of spider Society members with
each having its own distinct look and
visually striking animation and speaking
of that we actually got to sit down with
the cast and ask them about their
favorite and here's what Jake Johnson
had to say everything in this movie The
Animation is so wild it's like pushing
so many boundaries that at times I'm
just kind of like what are they doing
now right like the Lego world was really
neat do you ever wear like jumps into a
Lego Universe for a little bit and I'm
like man what is happening yeah so yeah
yeah I mean there's there's too much you
got to kind of see it but like there's
it's kind of there's too much to pick a
favorite I'm so excited I'm sure you're
so excited
and they also told us that Gwen Stacy's
world is going to change visually based
off what mood she's in kind of makes you
wonder what other universes they may
drop in on perhaps a live-action one
Toby anyone Tom Holland anyone a girl
can dream okay let's move on
[Music]
of course with all those new universes
comes the possibility of countless new
spider Heroes popping up and along with
the three main stars we've discussed
miles Gwen and Peter B Parker voiced by
shamik Moore Haley Seinfeld and Jake
Johnson who you just saw respectively we
know of at least a few more that are
joining in on the fun starting with Issa
Rae as the voice of a variant Jessica
Drew who was the original Spider-Woman
from Marvel's comic book Universe this
version is also seven months pregnant
which honestly to me is the coolest
thing ever I mean how many times do we
get to see a pregnant superhero on the
big screen there's also Daniel kaluya as
the voice of spider Punk and Karen Sony
as pavitier prabhakar an Indian version
of Peter who is commonly known as
Spider-Man India my name is
I live
and then there's a glimpses we've gotten
from the trailer showing tons of
incarnations from Comics video games and
past TV shows and my friends I'm talking
about everything from the PlayStation 4
game Marvel Spider-Man 2 the Spider-Man
Unlimited TV series and oh so much
everything in between
damn winner
and I probably should mention that we're
not sure if Nicholas Cage is Spider-Man
Noir or John Mulaney spider-ham are
coming back but I can tell you that I
sure hope they do we do know that Oscar
Isaac's Spider-Man 2099 who had a brief
Cameo at the end of the first movie is
going to be playing a really large part
in this one
Spider-Man
to come with who the heck are you I just
told you that listen listen I'm from the
future how dare you point at me large
enough in fact that it appears miles may
actually be at odds with him at some
point on top of dealing with all the
villains hey what do you know another
great transition
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go
I'm gonna do my own thing
[Music]
stop Spiderman let's talk about the
baddies so we know for sure that Miles
and his Spidey friends will be dealing
with one big Baddie named Jonathan own
aka the spot that's not funny
don't don't do that but if you've never
seen him his body's covered with little
portals that he uses to go almost
anywhere in the Multiverse and if that
sounds to you like the kind of thing
that might be a major issue for the
overall structural Integrity of the
Multiverse well gosh darn you were just
so smart
oh no I'm turning into my neighbor
Debbie so Jason Schwartzman is the voice
of the spot and let's be honest anytime
you can get Max J Fisher from
rushmorecast it's a win you just gotta
find something you love to do and then
do it for the rest of your life we also
know that Jorma Tacony will be in a
villainous role as a vulture in this
film but to what extent he is involved
we're really not sure but anytime you
can get a member of The Lonely Island in
your cast it's a win
pull it up
for me one thing is for sure it appears
that miles will be in over his head
again and will be seeking and receiving
all the help that he can get to keep his
and everyone else's universes is safe
all right we don't want to keep you all
day so let's get into our final points
Oh yay behind the scenes my favorite
okay so on the creative side of things
co-writer and producer Phil Lord returns
but this time his usual writing partner
Christopher Miller joins him on the
screenplay duties alongside fellow
writer David Callahan one out of here
I'm grounded Lord and Miller even though
they sound like a law firm are actually
quite the funny Duo as they've been
making us laugh for years with projects
like 21 and 22 Jump Street the TV show
last man on Earth the Lego and Lego
Batman movies which probably explains
the Lego world in this one Cloudy with a
Chance of Meatball films and so many
more so we can only expect good things
for this second Spider-Man film as they
have a pretty good track record
especially with sequels but we know that
they're not gonna end with just two
films in fact let's take a quick glimpse
into the future and see what's in store
for the Spider-Man society and More
Store more I mean I'm a real
Shakespearean goddess over here quick
break for a couple try with my Mayan D I
love chai tea what did you just say shy
DJI means D bro you're saying DT would I
ask you for a coffee coffee with room
for cream cream no no across the spider
verse was originally slated to release
on October 7th 2022 but we'll Now debut
on June 2nd 2023. the follow-up
Spider-Man beyond the spider verse a
title that suggests a potential MCU
crossover I'm very excited for that
potentially is scheduled for a March
29th 2024 launch but that is not all my
friends early in the sequels development
longtime Spider-Man producer Amy Pascal
revealed that the film will also serve
as a launching pad for spider women an
animated film focusing on steinfeld's
Gwen Issa Ray Spider Woman and silk
another spider themed hero who's also
set to get her own animated television
series from Lord and Miller
and now it is time for me to catch a
breath because that's a lot of spider
things now it's unclear if that animated
television series is going to be
connected to spider women but it
indicates that the spider-verse will be
a well-established part of our film
calendar in the decade to come and I am
not mad about it there's nowhere to run
sorry
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run but congratulations my friend we
made it through that web so that is
everything you need to know before you
go and see Spider-Man across the
spider-verse in theaters June 2nd mark
your calendars I'm Naz Perez thank you
so much for watching and listening and
be sure to rate and review this film at
rottentomatoes.com